went through that so many times yeah
where years would you go by and you'd be
like oh
i'm not talented there's so many backup
ways to make money now like i feel like
you guys could really be make a killing
on only fans
but not only that you mean bobby and i
having one together is what you're i
mean possibly what's an only fan oh well
oh because i've heard it before i wanna
use one to explain it to me it's
basically it's um
you're your own independent contractor
and you're putting out your own content
it can be sexually explicit and it can
be not it can be just feet picks but
people buy them piece by piece
is there a site that i go on yeah so
there's an only fan site
and then you can pay somebody yeah you
subscribe to someone essentially you're
right right so a human subscription
we're finally there so is
like are you one only fans no i've never
been on only fans yeah either have i
yeah but i have friends who have really
gotten addicted to only fans oh they get
addicted is it mostly sexual yes
yeah like for instance um you know cat
from fighter and the kid she does only
suggestive no like sexually explicit
stuff and that girl makes a killing on
like feet pics yeah yeah
really yeah so how much if gareth and i
had one yeah if we had one what what
could we do what would they suggested to
do like
yeah i guess
here i have some suggestions okay great
okay so i'm really a big fan of both of
your legs i think if we can do something
along the lines of like cracking a nut
between your thighs okay like doing just
certain objects right
between your thighs like we can do thigh
squeezing like yeah
masters
[Laughter]
yeah cracking and busting are two
different things
cracking holidays oh you're literally
cracking enough yeah so we're taking
walnuts oh i'll tell you like you're
just or watermelon depending on how good
would you no you're just squeezing
inanimate objects i love legs it's kind
of like you know like oddly satisfactory
like those videos yeah oddly satisfying
stuff that can be one how much do you
charge for that it's you name you name
your price babe like uh for you to start
we'd have to i thought that would
probably drive to do this well we could
do it here i mean we could meet in the
middle
or whatever where's the middle um
yeah
or yeah oxnard or we can do the parking
lot at magic mountain what we could do
is we could that's great too that's the
background that's where a lot of people
are doing that
you're going to see a lot of people
doing those we'll probably in the
background um but what we could do is we
could just like meet up twice a month
just get a bunch of content ready a lot
of you know
thigh squeezing stuff yeah we could
scissor a little bit oh yeah i was gay
for a weekend in vegas it'll be fine to
me yeah
that's what i just thought that but my
let's go get offended i'm not offended
all right but i want to be the curator
great all right so i have some really
great we could charge what a hundred
bucks a video oh that's steep i mean
we're
i mean that's ambitious about it well
hold on you can charge five dollars a
video and let's say let's say let's
suppose i'm not doing it for five
dollars i know we're not like that's a
little lower cameo yep it depends what's
between your legs right yeah so if it's
his dick between your legs then you
charge a hundred yeah that's where
we're really getting it you have to work
up to it five dollars for this and there
are tiers and you you work there'll be a
lot of time yeah i don't want to do it a
lot of tiers
it's worse than cameo to me so here's
like trisha pay test this is how she
prices it
so you guys can do like monthly
subscriptions
oh my fifty dollars a month and then
they block all your posts and you can
just post it i can't imagine valuing
myself higher than netflix look at your
list
can you imagine having the golf
i am like i'm a hulu subscription per
month yeah and she's a porn star trisha
no um either a million a month or
million a year yeah
oh my god she shows just some photos of
her in lingerie i think she made like
six million one year so she said right
really and and it's videos too
it depends you are your own you know
sometimes just talks to the camera and
that's it and people pay for that
oh that's crazy my whole life is like
reinventing it can i tell you something
george and gilbert are trying to plot
for me to manage my only fans
we're trying to have an angling they've
been angling to manage my only fans and
i'm going to say this to you yeah okay
you're a hot piece of lady you say pizza
i said hot piece of lady what the [ __ ] i
heard hot piece of lady without a
stutter go ahead
dude best friends best friend yeah yeah
i can feel it now best friend yeah yeah
yeah so your hot piece of lady right the
common phrase right and you're um
and i i'm not
for some reason and maybe i sh
maybe something that we should work on
but i'm really not when guys fawn over
you you're a cuck babe just say it
there's one word for you and it's cuck
what's a cuck mean you love the idea of
watching
someone else have sex with me no that's
not it if that's drawing the law i draw
the line at that but if they jerk off to
you it doesn't bother me
interesting how about they jerk off on
me hmm oh if do you have cellophane or
anything
[Laughter]
we're assuming you're in a jar of some
kind
like if they put down like some sort of
saran wrap right and they were jerking
off like nine guys were joking
before we came downstairs to meet you by
the way he offered me like a cow to
another man let's be real okay okay no
that's not let's let's be
that's not what happened like it's a
it's a strong accusation
[Laughter]
let's be clear here okay what
this woman right
watch your tongue fine piece of lady
yeah
smoother got her got her right this this
lady right comes back from hawaii right
and they're
all